there's been an alarming surge in the
number of infections and deaths from the
corona virus named by scientists s
Corbett 19 health officials are getting
increasingly worried and this is why a
surge in the number of infections which
is shot up to 60,000 worldwide
that's after some 15,000 new cases were
reported in just a day over 250 deaths
were recorded on Wednesday alone in the
Chinese province of Hebei the epicenter
of the outbreak Japan is also reported
its first death from the virus for the
very latest let me draw in correspondent
Matias billing er who's in a Beijing
latias what is the reason behind the
spike in infections and fatalities in
China it is indeed a new reporting
method the local authorities have
decided to include patients who show
clear symptoms of the virus pneumonia
but who are not tested positively for
the virus in to the statistics the
reason is that many patients could not
be tested so far because there is a lack
of laboratories and testing kits and we
are also hearing cases where people have
tested negative Leiby despite clear
symptoms that point to the corona virus
infection I have spoken to some of them
one woman told me that her mother who
was suffering from was suffering
severely could not be admitted into
hospital because she tested negative ly
twice despite her symptoms and only the
third test was positive so hopefully
this new method of counting will also
lead to more patients having a chance at
proper treatment because they can be
admitted to hospitals now it might also
mean that the queues for the hospital
beds will be longer and people and
people will still have to wait it is it
seemed that the first political
political consequences have take
place as about the way this crisis of
coronavirus is being handled in China
bring us up to date with what's
happening yes two major officials have
been replaced today the party secretary
of the province of Hebei that is the
person on top of the governor's or the
most senior person in the hierarchy of
this province and the party secretary of
Wuhan as well they have been replaced
this is not a surprise the local
authorities have been criticized widely
by the Chinese public and it's also
something that the central government
the Communist Party adopts off when it
has a crisis that it cannot handle it
tries to keep the plain blame on the
local officials in order not to get the
whole system affected by criticism what
we know about the new party secretary is
that he is somebody who seems to be
close to see Jinping he has started his
career in a province where Xi Jinping
was at the time the head of the province
authority and he has a background in the
security services in the police which
might point to strict control of the
population and possibly a crack and even
small severe crackdown on dissent in the
city but is Bulaga thank you very much
for that update on how China is handing
the corona virus epidemic
well EU health ministers have been a
meeting in Brussels for talks on
Europe's response to the virus earlier
DWS max Thunder went to Europe's
Emergency Response Center coordinators
there are working around the clock on
international efforts to help you
citizens get back home and stop the
virus from spreading a dramatic journey
coming to an end these passengers
disembarking from a German Air Force jet
in Frankfurt earlier this month were
among the first to be evacuated from
China to Europe due to the corona virus
it was a challenging task to organize
here at the European Commission in
Brussels Christian Jakob is helping
Europeans in China return home safely on
flights such as the one to Frankfurt in
the operation room of the Emergency
Response Center it's his job to oversee
all processes and coordinate help we are
in close contact with our Member States
by phone by email and through a special
ID information system we are in close
contact with the Chinese authorities in
order to receive updates from them
and to see which are the most needed
items that they need in order to contain
these disease the ER CC has been
coordinating the e use response to
global emergencies since 2001 during the
Ebola epidemic in western Africa the
organization oversaw assistance and
relief to the affected countries such as
Liberia valuable lessons that are
proving helpful today operations in
Brussels have taken up pace since
friends triggered an eu-wide emergency
response procedure over the corona virus
outbreak situation definitely is
worrisome this is what is an epidemic
this is a serious danger for public
health this virus as you know spreads
with great speed so measures have to be
taken and we are trying to see that they
are taken in a coordinated manner for
the EU getting its citizens out of China
is a first important step but with the
number of coronavirus cases growing
rapidly brussels and member states will
have to come up with a broader strategy
to prevent the disease from spreading on
European soil and EWS Lauren marina
Straus joins me now from Brussels Marina
you health ministers have wrapped up a
meeting where they discuss the corona
bars do they come up with a broader
strategy on how to deal with the
situation well first we have to say that
the number of infected people here in
Europe is still quite low we're talking
about 40 people have coronavirus and
that's also something that health
ministers here stressed that there is no
immediate need to panic but of course
with the rising number of cases in China
new member states are getting
more and more worry there so there's
definitely need to take action one thing
we heard the press conference that just
took place here in Brussels is that
information and communication are
actually key my colleague just talked to
German Health Minister yen span Minister
span which additional measures does
Europe does Germany need to prevent the
corona outbreak to evolve into a real
pandemic first of all what we do need is
an coordinated approach in Europe and
internationally and that is why we are
very much engaged in coordinating within
the European Union like today within the
council or within the g7 that we have
calls of the health ministers for for
example and what is important is
actually that we prepare and that we try
to [ __ ] actually as much as possible
that the virus reaches other regions
than China and is affecting it as much
as it is China so far it's just a
regional epidemic outbreak in China but
we need to be sure that it does not
become a real epidemic worldwide and if
so a pandemic worldwide if so we need to
be prepared to regarding research around
therapies and and and vaccination we
need to prepare to be prepared in what
we know about the virus every week we
have to prepare helps us to know more
about how infectious it is actually how
severe it can get for the patients and
all all these actions actually are
focusing on this getting gaining time to
know more do you seek to restrict travel
from into China as for example the
United States did what we already have
done in Germany's for example that we
asked pilots that they need to tell the
tower in advance if there are patient
passengers with symptoms are bought on
board or not and that passengers
actually have to fill out a form that
says where there are reachable contact
dates for the next 30 days we might need
additional measures to know which
passengers actually have been in contact
with people from the Wuhan region
for example and that is actually what we
have discussed here during the council
meeting but we do not need by the way if
I might add is from my point at least
fever measuring this for example taking
the the temperature of passengers
because we just know because of the
incubation time and the symptom free
time we have after infection it actually
doesn't help do you trust the numbers of
infections you get from the communist
regime in China well what we can see is
actually that there must be many more
cases and we actually do see in the in
the public figures why because they just
changed actually and the case definition
for for the statistic that only a case
goes into the statistic if there really
were symptoms and we know that there are
many many symptom free cases so I would
assume that there are many more cases
than we see in the statistic which is
important because if you take the cases
in relation to for example people that
died that makes a difference than for
the relation china on the other hand is
able to apply very draconian measures
locked down of whole cities would Europe
be able to do that if need be I would
say I'm impressed by what China does and
different regards actually but what we
see is for example with but if there is
a measles outbreak in Germany and
measles are much more infectious than
what we see with the corona virus so far
we actually are able to deal with it
without putting whole cities under
current time when will the worst be over
that's a good question if I knew that's
actually our our problem is that we
don't know enough about the virus that
is why there is ease that there are so
many measures actually that need to be
taken to prepare as long as we don't
know really what what it does for
example and how harmful it is and so far
in Europe and within European Union
detection and containment works we are
able to
to stop the infectious chains but we
have to admit that's today and it could
get worse before it becomes better
because as long as it is not under
control in China these regional epidemic
situation can develop to worldwide
pandemic situation and there's one issue
that health ministers discuss a lot or
they're there ice concerns over supply
chains actually because a lot of
chemicals used in pharmaceutical
products here in the EU actually come
from China and with productions being
blocked there might be shortages in the
connect coming days or even weeks and
that's something many are concerned
because if the virus should break out
here if more if more cases should be be
here then this could become an issue and
health ministers want the you Commission
to evaluate the situation and mareena
any kind of plan will require
coordination from all EU member
countries did you get the sense they
agreed on a common approach well the
thing is that health is actually a
national matter
so you member states can decide
themselves what kind of approaches they
want to take and that will be still
their right to do it for example Italy
will band all flights from China and to
China and that's their decision but the
pressure is actually high with more
people getting affected in China and all
around the world and they actually have
to align measures to to fight that virus
and that's something that everyone here
agrees on marinus Charles in Brussels
thank you very much